we learned over the weekend how a donald
trump fundraising scam
has imploded but not before donald trump
was able to
trick supporters and grift them out of
millions actually really tens of
millions of dollars now you might be
saying
you told us about this david you told us
about how
after trump lost in november of 2020
he raised what was it 70 something
million dollars
with the idea that he was going to use
it to
pay for recounts fight the results
support georgia's senate candidates what
were their names i'm even forgetting
kelly lefler and david perdue
and instead he kept the cash and he used
it to pay off campaign debts and all of
this other stuff
right that's true that's all true
but a bunch of those millions that he
raised came from people
who weren't trying to give him any more
money whose intention was to make a
one-time donation
but they were billed again and again and
again
and once again right-wing media is
silent on it
republican elected officials are silent
on it they're looking the other way
maybe because some of them are using
this same scam and we just haven't heard
about it yet so here's what happened
the new york times is a full report
explaining the ruse and it goes like
this
donald trump knew he was in trouble last
fall publicly at every rally he would
say oh
we've got uh look i've got great marks
here and i've got all these polls and
we're winning everything and of course
he wasn't and he knew he wasn't
but not only was the polling not looking
good
the fundraising was looking terribly
fundraising is not a matter of opinion
it's not well rasmussen says this and
ipso says that and the truth is in
between no
you know how many dollars are coming in
and they were in trouble
so what the trump campaign started doing
in september was to set up
recurring donations for online donors
so that the donations would keep
happening every week
up until election day now understand
that
in principle there's nothing scammy
about a recurring donation if that is
the norm
if that's what's expected if people
understand that that's going on
it's not the norman political
contributions if you sign up for cable
with
comcast and you're told this service is
75 dollars a month
and every month you keep having cable
you expect
you're going to keep getting built
that's the way it works we all for the
most part understand that
if you sign up for a gym membership and
they say beautiful
uh you know it's uh it's forty dollars
per month
and that includes access to you know the
weight room and uh
you expect that each month your credit
card is going to get
hit with a 40 charge that's what you
expect
in political donations the default is
you donate once and that's it
and the trump campaign started setting
up their fundraising website back in
september
to by default make whatever you donate a
recurring
weekly donation you had to go through a
fine print disclaimer
and then uncheck a box that was checked
by default
to avoid your donation being a recurring
donation
and then as the election closed in
trump's campaign did
even more to hide the disclaimer and the
opt out
and they even introduced a second
pre-checked box which i'm going to show
you in a moment
known to them as the money bomb which
increased a person's contribution
automatically programmatically going
forward
when individuals intended to make just
one donation so check out what this
looked like it's too
huge i'm showing it to the video
audience i know if you're
listening you can't see this but it's
two huge yellow boxes with a bunch of
bold
text which are checked by default and
the bold text is
all trump will win win win but then at
the bottom not in bold it says
make this a weekly recurring donation
until november 3rd
and then there's another one of these
yellow boxes with tons of bold text
about trump is a patriot
you're a patriot for donating and then
at the bottom not in bold
an escalator donate another hundred
dollars automatically on october 9th
can you imagine you know how we have
these borderline illegal membership
discounts that i offer people
even though i'm at risk of going to
prison because these deals i'm offering
you are so good
we offer these discounts if you use the
coupon code better21 you save 50
off forever right our discounts are
forever
trump did the opposite it's like a
reverse coupon code it's like if i had a
60
membership and then i hide a box where
your next renewal goes to 120.
don't worry i would never do that to you
our discounts are permanent
the scam netted trump millions and of
course
some people saw it on their credit card
and they filed a charge back
but tons of people did not and
incredibly tragically
there are individuals who fell for this
who were too sick and in the hospital to
fight the charges but the charges just
kept coming
one guy named victor amelino 78 year old
californian
he made a 990 online donation to trump
in september
and then it recurred seven more times
adding up to eight thousand dollars
and he told the new york times quote i'm
retired i can't afford to pay
all that damn money now some of the
money ended up being refunded some
people successfully disputed the charges
many did not these refunds
coincided with a surge of donors
calling credit card companies saying i
am a victim of fraud i've been
defrauded by trump fundraising
a wells fargo fraud investigator said
quote it started to go absolutely wild
now this is not for me about oh
feel bad for trumpists who got suckered
because the truth is
they got suckered by trump in terms of
even supporting him politically
and then they got suckered again with
the fundraising scam okay
someone wrote to me and said david screw
them they were dumb enough to fall for
trump's campaign anyway
screw them on the money as well okay
well maybe but this isn't really about
that
this is about how at every opportunity
donald trump ran his campaign like a
multi-level
marketing scam like trump university
and this is part of trump cares about
his supporters
only as far as they are useful to him
remember during the january 6th trump
riots
one of the reactions trump had as the
coverage continued
was that trump felt the low class and
sort of coarse nature of his supporters
was making him look bad that's how trump
views his supporters
he doesn't view them as people with whom
he's morally and politically aligned
who he wouldn't dare scam these are
mostly people
that as a rich dude from new york he
spent his life
trying to stay away from and he will
gladly scam them
and he did and he scammed them on
fundraising
and his entire presidency was a scam so
this has now been exposed by the new
york times
the fundraising i don't even think this
is the end
of the fundraising scams i think there
will be more let me know your thoughts
you can find me on twitter at d pacman
we are back
from vacation and there is so much to
talk about today
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plugin
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be because you
can destroy the virtual card number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank
or credit card info protected against
data breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like i said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at
privacy.com slash pacman